hi there Steve Kaufman here today I'm
gonna answer a question that I get all
the time how many languages do you speak
so I'm going to tell you how many
languages I speak and I'm gonna tell you
how many languages I know and I'm going
to do it with some explanation in some
detail
remember if you liked this video give me
a like it helps the ratings and if you
like my channel here please subscribe so
I'm often asked how many languages do
you speak and I think many polyglots are
asked this question and it's a difficult
question to answer because you know we
can have varying degrees of knowledge of
languages some languages we can just
speak right away if you ask me to say
something in my stronger languages I can
just start speaking not a problem but
then I have other languages where I have
a fair amount of knowledge but I can't
just turn them on so let me go through I
would say the first dozen languages
where I can speak now all right so
obviously English French and I'm gonna
go in sort of the order declining order
of proficiency so English then French
and when I say speak typically the
languages that I can speak the best and
the most confidently are the languages
that I have spoken the most so even
though I'm a great proponent of input
input based learning to build up your
capability in a language in order to
speak it well you have to have lots of
opportunity for real meaningful
conversations so obviously I have had
that in French I have added in Japanese
I have had it in Mandarin Chinese I have
had it in Spanish but less most of my
sort of practice using the language was
when I used to hitchhike in Spain in the
mid-60s hours and hours and hours of
sitting with truck drivers and other
people who picked me up
recently I have had far less opportunity
to speak Spanish then probably comes
Swedish because I was did a lot of
traveling in Sweden doing business and
German but both of those languages are
languages that I speak less well than
the first group simply because I don't
have as big a vocabulary I haven't done
as much listening
in them and I make more mistakes but I
can converse comfortably but with more
mistakes
then comes probably Italian where I have
traveled to Italy and so I can speak
that language
and then probably Cantonese and then
comes Portuguese which is very similar
to Spanish is almost like Spanish spoken
with a few different words and different
pronunciation but I've had less
opportunity to speak it some while in
Brazil some well in Portugal but really
not that much so that my Portuguese I
don't feel as confident it ends up being
a conscious effort to convert my Spanish
into Portuguese and I don't feel so
comfortable speaking it next comes
Russian where I have had a lot of input
lots of listening and reading some
opportunity to speak I was in Russia
briefly for a weaker 12 days back seven
or eight years ago and more recently I
was in Ukraine and particularly in Kiev
and eastern Ukraine
I was speaking Russian most of the time
but I can turn it on with mistakes but I
can turn it on
same with Ukrainian now which I learned
after Russian and I was in fact on
television in Ukraine in Kiev primetime
television speaking both Russian and
Ukrainian I understand the languages
well I speak Russian I understand
Russian much better but I understand
them both comfortably and I can speak
albeit with mistakes so that takes me I
believe unless I've forgotten the
language in there that should bring me
up to both 12 that I can say I speak
comfortably these are the languages that
I speak next comes a group of languages
where I have hardly had any practice
speaking but I have a fair degree of
understanding so these are languages
that I would say that I know but I don't
speak but it wouldn't take me more than
I mean Korean is saying next right and I
according to link I have 40,000 words
that I know in Korean but and when I was
in Seoul and I gathered with a group of
people there we had dinner and I was
speaking Korea but I haven't spoken much
Korean I've had a few isolated
conversations on
lying conversations I've worked at it
quite a bit but I don't feel comfortable
in saying that I speak it although you
know superficially it can sound as if as
if I speak it so but it wouldn't take me
more than a couple of days to get I
believe in a Korean environment to get
my Korean up to the level where I could
comfortably say I speak it and then I go
check polish you know Slovak that are
related languages here again I
understand them a lot of them anyway and
given an opportunity to be in that
environment I can elevate them to the
level of languages that I speak but I
don't like to say I speak them I'd like
to say I know them I know of them I'm
acquainted with them but I can't say
that I comfortably speak them so now
we've got the first twelve are the ones
that I speak the next four are ones that
I think I could you know I'm close to
being able to say I speak but I'm not
quite there yet because I haven't had
enough speaking experience then come the
languages that I've been working on more
recently
first of all remaining and Greek that I
put a fair amount of concentrated effort
into for a few months before going to
those countries and of course Romanian
is much easier than Greek because so
much vocabulary is similar to Italian
some of it is similar to Slavic
languages about 20% of it it's written
in the Latin alphabet and I found that
even after two months of a lot of input
based learning and some online tutoring
I was able to communicate in Romania
Greek I spent eight months at it it's a
different writing system there are fewer
sort of freebie vocabulary items and I
was able to communicate comfortably
while I was on the island of Crete in
both those languages if confronted today
by someone speaking Romanian or Greek I
wouldn't be able to say much if anything
at all so those are certainly not
languages that I speak but there are
like those are languages that I have
invested in and if I were to go back to
them go back to some of the material
I've been using to learn and start
speaking I could
again raise the level raise the level
but there's certainly not languages that
I can claim to speak now come my last
three languages Arabic Persian and
Turkish and they're my level is that
they are no longer unfamiliar to me I
know how they work I have you know in
Persian 2,500 words in Arabic 8,000
words and Turkish 6,000 words in some
ways Persian is the easiest of the three
because the structure is so similar to
European languages but of course the
writing system is a bit of an obstacle
and those are languages that I will be
working on all three of them over the
next year or so to gradually improve my
level will they ever reach the level of
the first 12 I don't think so
unless I spend a lot of time in Turkey
or in Iran or in an arabic-speaking
country and there the problem with
Arabic again is that I'm studying
traditional Arabic and there's no
country where that's the sort of
national language so but who knows maybe
I'll spend some time in you know Lebanon
and learn Levantine Arabic or in Jordan
or somewhere so there you have it it's a
summary of the 12 languages that I can
say that I speak four languages that I
could elevate to the level of languages
that I speak but I just consider them
languages that I know to languages that
I learned over a short period of time
which are at a lower level of
development and then the final three so
the total is 21 but only 12 of them can
I genuinely say that I speak ok thank
you and let me know what you think bye
for now
you